عشرات الهجمات الصاروخيه شنتها روسيا على
مدن رئيسيه في جميع انحاء اوكرانيا
واوكرانيا تقول انها صدت معظمها وكلمه
السر الدفاعات الجويه الغربيه فطوال فتره
الحرب استهلكت اوكرانيا انظمه الدفاع
الجوي من الحقبه السوفيتي التي حققت نسبه
نجاح تصل الى 80% بضرب صواريخ كروز
الروسيه وصلت دعم الغربي مع مجموعه متنوعه
من منظومه الدفاع منها بطاريته صواريخ
باتريوت الامريكيه قدمتها لاوكرانيا كل من
الولايات المتحده وايضا المانيا لصواريخ
باتريوت الاعتراضيه امكانيه على الاصابه
اصابه طائرات مقاتله عاليه وايضا متوسطه
الارتفاع وصواريخ كروز وبعض الصواريخ
الباليستيه منظومه لا تدافع وحدها عن سماء
اوكرانيا فكياف تلقت المزيد من صواريخ
الدفاع الجوي قصيره ومت المدى من دول
النتوء الاخرى تشمل هذه بعض الانظمه
المتاحه الاكثر تقدما مثل بطاريات ايرس تي
اللمانيه التي يصل مدى صواريخها الى
اربعين كيلو مترا وحققت بحسب قاده
اوكرانيين نجاحا بنسبه 90% ايضا من
المنظمات التي تبرع فيها او تبرع فيها
حلفاء اكياف من المنظومات منظومات ناس
الامريكيه ووافق وزير الدفاع الامريكي فقد
تمكنت المنظومه من النجاح بالنسبه 100% في
منع الصواريخ والمسيارات الروسيه فضلا عن
المتوفر لاوكرانيا حاليا تعمل الدول
الحليفه على امداد كياب بالمزيد من
المنظومات والصواريخ للوقوف بوجه الهجمات
الروسيه وبحسب مركز الدراسات الاستراتيجيه
والدوليه الامريكيه ربما تعمل روسيا على
استنزاف المخزون الغربي وقدره الدفاعات
الجويه الاوكرانيه لكن موسكو تواجه على
الجانب الاخر اصرارا غربيا على مواصله دعم
كاف عسكريا
وجعلته الدول الغربيه اولويه لها في
المرحله الحاليه
يجب ان نتذكر مقدار الجهد الذي كلفته مثل
هذه الاسلحه بالنسبه لاوكرانيا مقدار
الوقت والطاقه والحجج والاجتماعات والعمل
الذي سمح لنا ببناء مثل هذا النظام
الدفاعي الجوي هذا عمل هائل واشكر كل من
شارك فيه يوما بعد يوم وشهرا بعد شهر يعمل
فريقنا لضمان حصولنا على حمايه اجوائنا
اعتدنا ان نسمع ان حصولنا على صواريخ
باتريوت غير واقعيه والان ها هي باتريو
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات